- Can we see another
car you have in there?
- This is my '55 Buick Roadmaster.
When I came to Los Angeles,
I got off the plane at LAX,
I immediately went to the newsstand,
and I bought a copy of The Penny Saver,
that's like one of those
advertisement things,
you know, you buy things to sale.
And I was looking for a car,
'cause in LA you need a car
before you need a place to live.
'Cause you can't get a place
to live unless you get a car.
So I saw this advertised for
350 bucks, and I bought it,
and I've had it since 1972.
I met wife in this car,
we dated in this car,
I got married in this car.
I took this car to my first Tonight Show.
I took it to my last Tonight Show.
I'll tell you this story my wife hates,
my wife hates this story,
but it's kind of funny,
'cause we had our first
encounter in this car.
(laughs)
- Encounter.
On our 25th wedding anniversary,
I said "Let's try and recreate that."
So we both got in the car,
and we drove to where
we had our encounter,
but now it's a housing development.
So I'm like, "Okay, I think
it's right where that house is."
Okay.
So we pull up the street, okay?
And the house is like right there.
So, you're not as agile
at 25 as you are at 50.
(laughs)
And then's it sound like,
"Ow, my hair!",
and the horn's beeping,
it's like two o'clock in the morning,
I see the porch light come on,
the guy comes running,
"What's going on out here?"
Nothing, nothing, excuse me.
And that then also, the second encounter
was not as successful
as the first encounter.
But we had a lot of
laughs, it was pretty fun.
- That's pretty much how
marriage goes though, right?
The second letter was different.
(laughs)
Just kidding.
- Exactly.
- I'm just kidding.
No that's awesome.
I think you've found the love of your life
and you can make out in the car.
I've made out with my
man at the car as well.
That's a sexy car though,
that's a really cool car.
- A car like this, this is such a big car.
And you don't even have a radio,
you need just bring in live acts.
(laughs)
Oh my God, this is play
right there with you.
- Yeah.